if you're ready so um okay
uh welcome to the last seminar on in
this seminar series
and uh this week we have two speakers we
have kaushik malik from
max planck institute
giving the first talk on a negotiation
framework for distributed reactive
synthesis
and we have a second talk by kishore
jyothi murugan from the university of
pennsylvania
and so first kaushik will talk and
then uh so i think
you can start kaushik
please unmute yeah
yeah okay good uh thank you for the
introduction
and uh yeah i'd like to thank all the
organizers for
inviting me to give a talk here
so i'm going to uh present a recent work
that i
did with rupak anikatrinshmook and
damian zuferai here at max planck
institute
for software systems in german
and this is still an ongoing project so
uh the problem that we consider in this
work
is uh the distributed reactive synthesis
where we have a system
uh that has multiple interacting uh
components
and we want to synthesize distributed
controllers
for these components so that certain
given specifications are satisfied
and our approach involves
the components engaging in a negotiation
in order to resolve conflicts
by means of making promises and return
promises to each other
so before we go into the details of
the technical details let me first
explain the
the basic idea of the negotiation uh
using a very simple intuitive example
so suppose that we have a drone and a
vehicle
and they have been assigned a task of
delivering two different
objects of two different colors due to
locations in a building
suppose that there is also some external
disturbance such as
a gust of wind or maybe some
some water spills on the floor which
hinders the movement of the
of the of the two robots and the final
overall
objective is to come up with distributed
controllers
for these two systems so that this
specification is satisfied
no matter what disturbance we are
experiencing during run time as long as
the disturbance
comes from some bounded range which is
known after arrived
now uh to make this a bit more
interesting let us assume that none of
the two systems can actually satisfy the
specification on its own
so for instance the drone can fly to
level one
but uh because of this narrow
passageways here uh
it cannot uh navigate through it and it
might collide
in the presence of the wind and assume
that the vehicle
uh on the other hand uh if it is in
level one it can even though it can
navigate
and deliver the orange box but it cannot
reach level one in the first place
uh unless the drone uh takes it and
drops it and
like uh carries it and drops it to level
one
so we can see that uh these kind of
problems often uh gives rise to uh
situations where the
the components or the agents they need
to collaborate uh
with each other in order to fulfill some
task
now if there was a central server which
had access to
the models of the systems and the task
specifications
then this central server could serve the
role of a supervisor
and do a centralized synthesis and then
uh
could then uh decompose the the
synthesized plan in terms of
a local decentralized controller and
pass to the individual systems
and this type of centralized or at least
semi-centralized approaches uh
have uh uh have uh been used by other
authors uh
in term in the context of distributed
reactive synthesis
but in this work we assume that there is
no such
central server moreover we assume that
the systems have only a an imperfect
view of the other systems model and
this prevents one of the system playing
the role of a central server
and doing the centralized synthesis now
the problem of distributed reactive
synthesis is known to be undecidable
thanks to a seminal work of paulian
rosner from 1990
what we propose in this work is a sound
and incomplete
uh solution of the problem where the
components they engage
in a negotiation with each other and
come up with
some distribution of the task and uh the
output the outcome of the negotiation
is a set of assumed guarantee contracts
which are basically a formalization of
promises
made to the other components and these
assumed guarantee contracts are
specified using the interface variable
in this imperfect information channel
and uh because of because we are using
this assumed guarantee contracts over
these
interface variables our approach is also
modular
in the sense that once the negotiation
has been completed and we have obtained
these contracts now we can uh plug and
play
uh different uh components in the system
as long as their basic uh
functionality is the same and also the
interface variables they do not change
uh by the switching of components
uh now uh let me show you how this
negotiation algorithm
will look like at a very intuitive level
for this particular example
so the negotiation let's say the the
vehicle uh starts this negotiation
process
so uh what it does is it first does some
computation
and uh it it it it realizes that uh on
its own
it can only deliver the yellow box
because it can reach level 0 without
any problem but not the orange one so it
tells the
drone that you delivered the orange box
and let me do the yellow one
now notice here here that the vehicle
because it has an imperfect information
of the drone
it does not know what the drone is
capable of so namely it does not know
that the drone cannot
uh do this task that is that it is
asking for
so uh now the drone uh does some
computation again and it uh
it realizes that it cannot do what the
vehicle is asking for it does this to
the vehicle and
it in exchange it suggests that let me
do uh the yellow box because there is no
obstacle in
level zero and you can do the orange box
um now uh the vehicle uh it realizes
that it cannot reach
level one uh unless the drone can help
it
so the vehicle asks the drone okay so i
can do what you are asking for but then
you have to first help me to reach
level one and uh the for the drone this
is a perfectly uh plausible uh plan
because uh first it can uh take the
vehicle to
uh level one and after that it can take
care of the yellow box and that way both
of the boxes will be delivered
so this is how they uh reach a
successful negotiation and uh
in the end uh what we get is uh this set
of promises that they made to each other
and uh this set of promises are
formalized as i already mentioned using
assumed guarantee contracts
so what are they so the assumed
guarantee contract for the drone
is consists of two parts so the first
part is the assumption part
which is the promise made by the vehicle
which is the other system to the drone
and the second part is the guarantee
part which is the promise made by the
drone to the vehicle
right and similarly this is symmetric
for uh the vehicle as well
now uh once uh the negotiation uh has
ended and if and as i mentioned if you
remember that the negotiation is a sound
uh but incomplete procedure in our case
so if you manage to find
uh such set of contracts so then uh what
what we need to do
is uh we need to replace the the given
task of these two systems
by uh this augmented specification so
where now
instead of uh considering the the given
task we are
uh we only are interested in finding a
controller
uh for uh this specification so what it
says so the first part says that
the specification now needs to be
satisfied only when the assumption is
fulfilled by the other system
and the second part says that the
contract needs to be fulfilled
so let us so the first part is just when
assumption and specification are omega
regular properties so the first part is
also an omega regular property
so let us uh uh try to understand what
this second part
is like what does it exactly mean to
satisfy a contract
well we say that the drone will satisfy
the contract
if it can position itself uh
in the in the in the beginning in such a
way that
uh in future uh there is a strategy to
satisfy
uh the guarantees now from all the
next time steps what is what the drone
has to uh
do is to ensure that the guarantee is
satisfied
only if the specif the assumptions have
been satisfied
by the vehicle in all the past time
instances
and if the drone has a strategy so that
this this
uh this conditional satisfaction of the
contract is uh uh
can be fulfilled then we say that the
drone can realize the contract
and similarly for the vehicle so now
once we
uh have the contract from the
negotiation all we need to do is we need
to modify the specification and then we
need to
find the strategy which is a realization
strategy for
these uh augmented specification and
that will be the controller that we were
looking for
in the beginning um
and what we get out of this
is uh if the if both of the systems they
satisfy
their assumed guarantee uh contracts
then this will
imply uh with the chain of inequalities
uh the satisfaction of the specification
and this can be roughly uh
shown by uh by doing an induction over
time
now uh this type of assumed guarantee
reasoning for
circular systems it's not nothing it's
it's not anything new so this has been
uh
in existence in uh verification
community or in other
synthesis contexts as well but mostly
what we have realized is that people
look into people assume that the
contracts are given and uh
we are interested in proving correctness
of by by
by proposing some proof rule but here
what we are
doing what is new in some sense is that
we are starting from the system model
and the specification and then we are
synthesizing the contracts
in such a way that they are compatible
now the closest related work is uh
perhaps uh
this uh 2015 paper by rajiv and others
where they do a pattern based refinement
of those human guarantee contracts
so uh but in their work unlike us they
only consider one-way
interaction uh between the system and uh
uh and so so you can see uh whereas
we consider two-way interaction uh among
the system
and uh also uh we use a completely
different kind of
approach in our work
so uh the plan for the rest of the talk
is that i am going to now go into the
technical details of
how we can uh define the problem like
what
what what is the kind of system that we
consider what is the kind of
specification
and then after that and i'll i'll do
this using this uh
example of uh of the drone and the
vehicle and after that i will use that
to uh to to show how the negotiation
process look like
looks like you know at a technical level
and then finally i will close with
some experimental results so
now uh the we assume that
the system models are given to us in the
form of
uh finite state transition systems and
these transition systems so uh so this
is the
transition system for the drone and this
is for the vehicle and
these transition systems they
essentially capture
the three-way interaction between the
system the other system
and the external environment now uh
so the vertices of these transition
system they are the states of the system
and the labels that we that you see here
they are
basically uh the observable behavior the
observable behavior of the system
so meaning that uh when the drone is in
uh
let's say when the vehicle is either of
these two states
so then the drone observes uh the idle
behavior from the vehicle
and observe that uh for one observable
behavior the
the system can be in multiple multiple
possible states
and this is the partial observability
that i previously talked about
um now uh let us uh okay so now uh the
three-way interaction that i mentioned
uh is uh modeled using uh using a
turn-based uh
fashion so where we have uh partition
the state space of the
of the system into three parts so the
first
type of states are the ones which are
the circles which are controlled by
the system which means that when the
system is
in a circular state the system can
choose one of the outgoing edges to
choose the successor
when the uh when the system is uh in
one of the diamond shaped states so
these are the environment
control states and the environment uses
the successor and these are shown by
dashed arrows
and when the system is in a square state
so these are the states which are
controlled by the other system and as
you can see that
the transitions the outgoing transitions
from the square states are labeled with
the observables of the other systems so
here
when we are in weight when the drone is
in wave state
so then it can either go to a or remain
here depending on whether the
other system is producing observable
capital a or idle
um now there are these special states
uh orange and yellow and we have labeled
here in this case uh the
the boxes a and b and we assume for
simplicity that
it is required that a needs to be
delivered before b
so here the orange states are basically
uh
the those states of the drone where the
drone has
sensed that a has been delivered and the
yellow state is the one where the drone
has sensed that both of the boxes have
been delivered
right and uh yeah and so now if we
if we look at the overall uh transition
and what
uh what it means is that you can see
like what
so this basically models all the uh
features that i mentioned earlier
that when the drone tries to deliver a
then the
environment can make it crash to the
wall and it might
not be able to satisfy the specification
whereas uh
uh uh the other option for the drone is
to lift the vehicle to level one and
then wait for the vehicle to
uh deliver a and then after that deliver
b and so on and similarly for the
vehicle
right and uh now given uh these two
uh uh these kind of transition system
for these two
uh uh components and given their local
specifications uh uh in terms of some
omega regular properties
uh specified using their states of the
system so okay so one thing i forgot to
mention here
for simplicity i assume that the
specifications are the same for both of
the system but this does not have to be
the case
so given all these ingredients what we
want to achieve is one we want to
uh find a procedure that will give us a
pair of assumed guarantee contracts for
these two systems
and notice here that for the drone
the assumption has to be given in terms
of the observable behavior
of the of the of the vehicle whereas the
guarantee has to be given
in terms of the observable behavior of
the drone itself and similarly for
the vehicle right so by the way
so please feel free to ask questions if
you haven't
so uh if this was clear uh then uh
let me uh straight away jump to the
the negotiation algorithm
so now uh the negotiation algorithm uh
is an iterative procedure
so it uh it proceeds in uh in rounds
uh and initially one of the system
starts the negotiation let's say the
drone starts the negotiation so
initially
uh it has the trivial contract which is
which says so here the top symbol means
like all possible behaviors are allowed
so here it means that the drone assumes
that all possible behaviors are allowed
from the vehicle
and in in return the drone can also
produce any all possible behaviors and
this is the drones
in the specification itself so uh
initially uh we start with this kind of
contract and what we do is in every
iteration
we uh keep on refining the current
contracts
based on uh yeah we keep on refining the
current contracts and
yeah and uh one one possibility is that
uh in the beginning
uh both of the systems can satisfy their
specifications without any help from the
other system
in that case there is no need for any
negotiation in that case the
the trivial contract the pair of trivial
contracts is
the uh outcome of the negotiation you
can say
otherwise as you can see here uh the the
the drone uh which wants to reach a b it
might need some help
uh to resolve these kind of self loops
from the other system so let's see how
it proceeds
so first uh the drone realizes
that this move like where it starts from
in it
for from the initial state and if it
goes towards the left so then the
environment which is the external
entity and this is adversarial from
which we cannot expect any help
can uh can make the system crash
and make the system uh lose the game
like falsify the specification
so this is not an option right so the
other two parts
so there the uh vehicle can uh
producing this idle observable can uh
trap the drone in these two states
forever right and the drone might not be
able to reach av
so what the drone now needs to tell is
to come up with some
sufficient assumption on the behavior of
the vehicle
so that uh that will allow the drone to
satisfy its current specification right
and uh we uh we we only restrict
ourselves to
uh safety languages for specifying this
sufficient assumption and this is simply
because
it is not clear to us like how to uh
prove correctness of
circular assume guarantee reasoning when
the assumptions and guarantees are given
to us as liveness languages
and so this is still a restriction and
as i said this is still
an ongoing work and here i
one thing i would like to say here okay
so here uh first of all uh you can you
can verify that this is indeed a
sufficient assumption so what it says is
that uh in the next
two time steps from the beginning uh
idle should not occur
so and that will enable the drone to
immediately uh
so after reaching weight immediately
move to a right so we are basically
blocking the self loops to
uh happen uh at all i mean another
option would be
uh that uh to be a bit more relaxed
bit more lenient and say that idle
should not occur after end time step or
so on
and yeah this is perfectly possible
where instead of this two you can you
could you can have any
like bounded number bounded uh integer
there
now the way we uh come up with this safe
sufficient assumption this involves a
solution
of some instance of reactive synthesis
problem and
this actually uh is an adapted version
of
the algorithm that has been proposed by
krishnan the chatterjee and others in
this
2008 paper so now uh
that we have obtained this first set of
assumption from the
drone the vehicle this the vehicle now
needs to uh take this assumption into
account as
a part of guarantee that it needs to
provide in future rounds of the
negotiation
right and uh now uh that
the so now the the vehicles effective
specification is this one it still
doesn't have any assumption yet because
it hasn't
made any assumption uh so far and now uh
the vehicle now has to again come up
with some additional set of assumptions
that are required
so for instance uh if it wants to uh
make sure that uh this guarantee is
satisfied
so it has to make sure that this self
loop here uh is uh not taken by the
by the drone right i mean otherwise uh
there is no way the vehicle can avoid
producing an idle in the second time
step so
yeah sorry five minutes yeah yeah okay
uh and uh uh yeah and
uh the second part comes from the fact
that the vehicle also has its own
specification
right and uh this uh gives us uh this
gives us a uh
the new set of assumption which now the
drone has to take into account as a set
of guarantees
and also the set of assumption that
the drone uh made in the previous round
of the negotiation they also
come here as part of the contract now
and
you can see like now the drone can
satisfy the specification
and this new specification by taking uh
this part
and uh this will essentially end the
negotiation and
uh in the end we get these as our output
contracts uh
uh right and uh
yeah and the features of this
negotiation uh
as i already mentioned is that it is
sound but incomplete
uh and uh this is incomplete due to
various reasons uh
we have made some uh yeah we have made
some remarks in the paper if you are
interested
please do check um okay i have a
question
yes the uh
why do you want to use uh temporal logic
here instead of
say automata to capture these uh
assumptions particularly when you are
refining them
yeah so so actually they are uh they are
uh represented using automatic using a
regular automata and they are safety
languages
but here i used temporal logic just for
uh
just for simpler uh presentation purpose
okay okay that makes sense yeah yeah
okay uh so uh yeah so i will just
quickly go over the experiment so we
uh we implemented uh this negotiation
algorithm in a tool called agnes and uh
we performed a bunch of experiments so
one of them
is this mutual exclusion example where
there are two processes they are trying
to send some data
over using a shared bus and there is no
handshake protocol
involved so each time they want to share
a data they just need to write it in the
transmission end
and the data will be shared and if
both of them are trying to write the
data at the same time
then the bus rejects the data from both
of them in order to avoid corruption
and now uh they are they both of them
have some deadline
in order to uh before when uh they need
to uh
send the data and now you can imagine
like uh there
they need to somehow uh have some kind
of arrangement that uh
not both of them uh try to attempt to
send the data at the same time otherwise
they will be stuck forever
and uh when we applied our uh our tool
and we indeed found the uh found success
successfully found
contracts which enabled them to be able
to satisfy the specification
and this is actually a parametric
example where
the parameters are the number of data
packets and the deadline and so on and
by varying parameters we managed to
create
different instances of the problem with
different sizes of the state space so
the x-axis
here shows the size of the product state
and the y-axis shows the computation
time in seconds
and as you can see that even for
reasonably large
uh systems we managed to find solution
for
uh like within like one minute or so and
uh yeah these uh
contracts uh indeed like uh they they
turned out to be like
sound contracts uh that is we managed to
find uh successfully controllers for
them
uh to summarize um i
i i i showed you um
a sound modular and incomplete uh
approach
for distributed synthesis which kind of
mimics the negotiation procedure that
humans uh do all the time uh to resolve
conflicts
and uh uh the the inputs to the
procedure are the systems model
in using uh finite state transition
system and omega regular
specification over the local states and
uh
what we uh uh we we have the restriction
that the systems have
partial view of each other and
the output of the procedure is a set of
assumed guarantee contracts
and yeah and we also
we also propose some optimization
heuristic for faster computation which
basically compresses the assumptions
into smaller automata
and that is really useful for when the
negotiation goes uh for
many number of rounds and so on and
we implemented our procedure in this
tool called agnes which can be freely
downloaded
from this link thank you
thank you um any questions
so if you have a question you can either
write something on in the chat or you
can unmute yourself and ask
um perhaps i can ask the first question
uh can you explain what goes wrong if
your assumptions and guarantees are
liveness languages rather or you know in
general omega regular languages
rather than 50 languages
yeah i mean so basically we don't have a
correctness proof
of the circular assume guarantee
reasoning with
liveness uh assumption and liveness
guarantees yet
so the thing that works in safety is
that
we can uh we can we can look at back at
the traces and look back at the behavior
and judge whether the system had
satisfied the assumption or guarantee
but for liveness this is no longer true
because for liveness we now have to be
able to
see in the future whether something is
going to be
satisfied eventually or so on and this
is uh
uh this is a bit tricky it i i would say
there is no problem it's just that we
have not figured out
yet like how to do it okay thank you
any other questions
if not maybe i'll ask you to stop
sharing the screen
and and
let me thank you again on behalf of the
organizers and
perhaps we should we can move to
kishore's